>> Greg: NANCY PELOSI'S
IMPEACHMENT PROBLEM GETTING
WORSE.
SHE CLASHED IN A TENSE STANDOFF
LAST NIGHT WITH HER PARTY AND
NOW SHE'S CALLING FOR A SPECIAL
PARTY MEETING TOMORROW TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH IT.
DESPITE THE IMPEACHMENT RISK,
PELOSI SAYS THERE'S NOTHING TO
WORRY ABOUT.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO INCREASE
PRESSURE FOR IMPEACHMENT IN YOUR
CAUCUS?
>> NO.
>> Jesse: APPARENTLY PELOSI
HASN'T BEEN LISTENING THE PEOPLE
LIKE JERRY NADLER.
HE'S FUMING OVER DON McGAHN
SKIPPING HIS COMMITTEE'S HEARING
AND IS READY TO TAKE THINGS MUCH
FURTHER.
>> FIRST THING WE'RE GOING TO
DO, HOLD McGAHN IN CONTEMPT.
DEALING WITH A LAWLESS PRESIDENT
THAT IS GOING TO ANY LENGTHS TO
PREVENT TESTIMONY THAT DOES
IMPLICATE HIM.
>> THE PRESIDENT AND HIS LAWLESS
BEHAVIOR IS MAKING IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO IGNORE ALL
ALTERNATIVES INCLUDING
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Jesse: JUAN, YOU THINK
IMPEACHMENT IS A PROBLEM FOR
PELOSI OR TRUMP?
>> Juan: PELOSI.
>> Jesse: YOU DO?
WOW.
>> Juan: YEAH.
PELOSI MADE THIS CLEAR FOR IN.
NOT TO IMPEACH.
SHE WANTED A SERIES OF HEARINGS.
IF FACTS EMERGE THAT PUSH
PEOPLE, FINE.
OTHERWISE, SHE WANTED TO PURSUE
A DEMOCRATIC AGENDA.
SHE'S DOING IT BUT DOESN'T GET
MUCH ATTENTION.
THAT WAS HER STRATEGY, JESSE.
WHAT WE SEE IS TRUMP'S NOT
ALLOWING THE INVESTIGATIONS TO
GO FORWARD WITH HIS BLANKET
OBSTRUCTION NOT ONLY OF PEOPLE
IN DON McGAHN, DOCUMENTS, THE
JUDGE YESTERDAY JUST HAD TO SAY
THE FINANCIAL RECORDS MUST BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO THE CONGRESS.
TRUMP SAYS THAT'S A OBAMA JUDGE.
WE'RE GOING TO APPEAL.
THAT SLOW-WALKS IT FURTHER.
I THINK HE WANTS TO BE IMPEACHED
BY THE HOUSE BECAUSE HE WILL NOT
BE CONVICTED BY A REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY IN THE SENATE AND THEN
HE WILL SEE TO HIS GRIEVANCE
LOVING SUPPORTERS, THEY BEAT ME
UP, BUT I'M STILL STANDING.
THEY SENT MUELLER AFTER ME, I'M
STILL STANDING.
THEY IMPEACH ME, I'M STILL
STANDING.
NOW HE'S A VICTIM FOR
CONSERVATIVES.
>> Jesse: YOU'RE NODDING YOUR
HEAD.
YOU AGREE THAT TRUMP WANTS TO BE
IMPEACHED IN THE HOUSE?
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE THAT TOM
SAWYER STORY WHERE YOU TRICK THE
KID TO PAINTING THE FENCE BY
EXAGGERATING THE BENEFITS.
GO FOR IT.
DO IT.
THE GREATEST.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO TURN
HIM -- I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT
VICTIMIZATION.
IT'S ABOUT --
>> Juan: WAS THAT CLARK KENT?
>> Greg: I REALIZE IS -- IT'S
FOLKS HERO STATUS WHEN YOU GO
AFTER SOMEBODY.
HE HAS A GREAT ECONOMY GOING.
ALL OF THIS GOOD STUFF IS
HAPPENING AND YOU'RE IMPEACHING
HIM?
IT'S GOING TO TURN HIM INTO PAUL
BUNYAN.
BUT THIS IS MY NEW THEORY.
TRUMP WILL GET REELECTED BECAUSE
THIS IS ALL THEATER.
LITERALLY HE HAS BECOME A SIX
THEATER AMC MULTIPLEX.
HE HAS OVER SIX MOVIES PLAYING
AS THE SAME TIME.
IN ONE THEATER, TWEET STORM.
ANOTHER ONE, YOU HAVE NORTH
KOREA, EXECUTIVE ACTION.
ANOTHER ONE, A ECONOMY ON FIRE.
ANOTHER ONE, YOU HAVE CELEBS
MELT DOWN.
THEN YOU HAVE COLLUSION
PSYCHOSIS.
THEN YOU HAVE RALLY FEVER.
AND THEN YOU HAVE FAMILY
AFFAIRS.
RATED R.
SO YOU HAVE SO MUCH TO CHOOSE
FROM, RIGHT?
THE MOVIES ARE NOT VIOLENT.
THEY'RE FUN.
EVERYBODY IS HAVING A GOOD TIME.
HE'S GOING TO BE RE-ELECTED.
YOU'RE MAKING MORE MOVIES.
>> Jesse: BIG BOX OFFICE FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
TOMORROW MORNING, PELOSI WILL
GET ON THIS NONE CALL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT WILL BE
LIKE?
>> Dana: OBVIOUSLY PRESSURE.
THE OTHER THING VERY
INTERESTING, SO FAR SHE'S BEEN
ABLE TO KEEP EVERYBODY PRETTY
MUCH IN LINE.
NOW YOU SEE PEOPLE THAT DISAGREE
WITH HER WILLING TO GO OUT AND
DO INTERVIEWS.
THEY'RE ON THE RECORD, TWEETING
ABOUT IT, OPENLY IN REVOLT.
SO I THINK SHE HAD TO HAVE THIS
PHONE CALL.
EVERY REPORTER YOU KNOW WILL BE
ON THE PHONE CALL.
WE'LL IN SOME WAY FIND OUT ABOUT
THE PHONE CALL.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS 98%
UNDER IMPEACHMENT.
JUST MAKING IT OFFICIAL WILL
MAYBE CHANGE A LITTLE BIT.
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING ALL OF THE
THINGS BASICALLY TO IMPEACH
SOMEBODY.
ALL THE DOCUMENTS, THE
TESTIMONY, ALL OF THE REQUESTS.
SHE HAS THE SUPPORT FROM THE
DEMOCRATS BUT THE NATIVES ARE
RESTLESS.
THEY'RE SAYING WAIT, SHE TOLD US
WE HAVE TO WIN THE MAJORITY IN
ORDER TO HOLD PRESIDENT TRUMP
ACCOUNTABLE.
NOW SHE'S SAYING, WE CAN'T HOLD
THE PRESIDENT ACCOUNTABLE
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO KEEP THE
MAJORITY.
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THAT GRASS
ROOTS ARE FRUSTRATED.
>> Jesse: SHE DOESN'T WANT
PEOPLE IN SWING DISTRICTS HAVING
TO TAKE A TOUGH VOTE ON
IMPEACHMENT.
IT'S AN UGLY VOTE ON AN ELECTION
YEAR.
>> IT'S WRAPPED UP IN WITH THE
REVOLT.
WHAT DO THE CONSTITUENTS FEEL?
A TON OF PEOPLE, DEMOCRATS, THAT
RAN IN 2018 AND THAT WAS ON
LET'S LET THE MUELLER REPORT
PLAY OUT.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE CRYING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT WEREN'T THE ONES
RUNNING IN BATTLE STATES.
THERE'S THAT SECTION.
SO IN THAT REVOLT, REVEALING
TRUE COLORS.
BUT ALSO EVEN PEOPLE LIKE, FOR
EXAMPLE, SENATOR WARREN WHO SAID
OH, WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S
UPHOLDING THE CONSTITUTION MEANS
MORE THAN THE PARTY.
IT'S STRATEGY -- WHEN STRATEGY
COMES INTO PLAY, IT'S SO OBVIOUS
BECAUSE IF IT MATTERED TO THE
DEMOCRATS, GETTING TO THE TRUTH
OR THE BOTTOM OF EVERYTHING,
THEY WOULD MAKE A GREATER DEAL
ABOUT MUELLER TESTIFYING.
AND IF THEY CARED ABOUT --
>> Juan: THEY'RE MAKING A BIG
DEAL ABOUT MUELLER.
>> Emily: NO.
IT'S ABOUT McGAHN NOW.
>> Juan: THEY WANT MUELLER TO
TESTIFY.
MULER IS THE ONE THAT IS HOLDING
BACK.
I THINK TRUMP IS SAYING HE
DOESN'T WANT McGAHN TO TESTIFY.
THIS IS ABOUT REFUSAL TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE REQUIREMENT OF
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT.
>> Dana: THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING
BACK TO THE WHITE HOUSE TO TALK
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT WILL BE FUN.